hey 42 here there are hidden oil wells
all over Los Angeles these secrets oil
wells are hidden right in plain sight
somewhere next to schools and shopping
malls
some are discretely concealed inside
playing boring old office blocks these
cleverly designed buildings are all like
we've got nothing to hide but that bang
oil well these discreet oil wells have
produced millions of barrels of crude
oil over the years in the 1890s Los
Angeles then a small town with a
population of just 50,000 was a thriving
oilfield the ground beneath the city is
rich in petroleum by 1930 California was
producing 1/4 the world's oil la grew
exponentially and it is now one of the
most densely populated cities in the
world most inhabitants are under the
impression that the oil industry that LA
was built upon has mostly dried up and
operations cease long ago but this
couldn't be further from the truth the
bustling city still produces oil at an
astonishing rate and every year more
secret oil wells are built around the
city most of the time your local
residents have no idea they are living
near an oil well in the thirties when
LA's oil industry was booming and people
for this sticky black cruised off was
the next best thing since the invention
of canning beer 95% of Los Angeles
residents actually voted former law but
allowed oil wells to be placed in one's
own backyard
could you imagine that today congressman
will be scalped and lynched by an army
of angry soccer moms at the slightest
mention of such a law but because of
that 1930s law today every quiet
suburban la neighborhood has its very
own
penguin killing vegan hating black gold
mine the ability to hide oil wells
behind or inside buildings is funks to
advances in technology which means oil
wells are now significantly smaller
quieter more efficient and generally
less messy than they were in the 20th
century actually due to advances in
soundproofing technology urban oil wells
are now almost completely silent
as the results oil wells have popped up
in the strangest of places amongst the
metropolis at 3.9 million people such as
smack bang in the middle of residential
areas McDonald's parking lots and even a
farmers market would you like some
petroleum with your organic fair trade
free-range avocados mum what you've
never had free-range avocado so all this
means that somewhere in a boardroom in
the headquarters of some giant Oil
Corporation there's a group of men in
suits playing a game of where's the most
stupidly obvious yet surprisingly
deceptive place we can hide in oil well
whilst that mic in a playground disguise
is a climbing frame that's genius
you win child hating oil baron of the
Month award but some haven't even
bothered to cleverly blend into the
surrounding environments some take the
other approach of if we erect the tall
building of a suspicious like if
markings or branding on it nobody will
notice it's an oil well today there are
over 3,000 active oil wells in Los
Angeles and more are sneakily built by
urban oil ninjas every year like this
one that was built directly in the
school yard of one of the poshest
schools in the country schooling the
little tyrants of the filthy rich at
Beverly Hills high school but they
painted some flowers on it and named it
the Tower of Hope so they could be all
like oh you're welcome
there's no oil wells over here the
company behind this particular well van
OCO has to pay leasing royalties to the
high school every year so much in fact
that 85 percent of the school teachers
wages come from this oil money ok now
this one isn't even trying to hide these
thoughtfully plate wells are inside a
cemetery near Signal Hill I suppose
they're hoping at the decomposing bodies
will contribute to the oil supply so I
guess that's kind of eco friendly kind
of like recycling oh what's that
it it takes a few million years to make
fossil fuel from their bodies oh well
sorry guys
rest in petroleum thanks for watching he
had simply gotten drunk at a local pub
and was walking home past a palace at 7
a.m. when he decided to go for a stroll
through the halls
possibly the world's most famous
residents just outside of Munich lies a
sleepy village called fuguro
where the rent for a whole year is just
under one euro